full complement of players to be
consistent they whip the Lakers a couple
of nights ago
hello recording with a long period the
play when we come back he'll shoot free
throws right now he makes his third
three in a row
[Music]
harden steps back Boulder Brian gets
again
of us would have taken it looked at
offered us in a heartbeat
15 billion from Trevor to show me where
to sign
wait a minute Three's bond this one he
takes just a half second more gets his
rhythm hits his legs need to cut harden
off tonight but they forgot all about
Chris Paul
I think he's reminding him that I can
still score fellas
pardon grips afraid for Houston Chris 14
Eric Gordon back out Green
[Applause]
fear in a lot of people's hearts he's in
an open court with the basketball same
for this guy's step back yes shot clock
at four seconds down to three harden
puts it up in hips I mean it's like
money right here it is that was deep
Gary Clark marks got it
26 three-pointers for the Houston
Rockets a new NBA record but here it is
Michael carter-williams a new NBA
records set tonight by the Houston
Rockets with 26 three-pointers